Like we discussed before,
Power BI is really three tools layered together.
You have Power Query,
get and transform data or what's often referred to as extract,
transform, and load, the data modeling layer,
and then finally the report layer.
These three layers together are pretty great set of
tools that empower users to work with the data that they've got,
rather than the data they would ideally like to have.
Enabling users to leverage these kinds of tools is something that
Microsoft has been moving towards for the better part of a decade,
though they were originally made available as separate technologies.
Let's talk briefly about how the technologies used in Power BI developed so that you
can better understand why it was created and
how it fits in with other tools in this area.
Starting back in 2005,
the vertipaq engine that drives
Power BI calculations was first made available as part of MS SQL.
The vertipaq engine functions as a ad hoc in-memory database which is
awfully useful when you're working on
a BI project and don't have a formal database to rely on.
But in 2010, the engine was then repurposed to
also serve as the guts of a new technology in the form
of Power Pivot and Power Query that
allowed Excel users to create data models with a simple atom.
A couple years later,
a visualization layer called Power View became available in Excel.
This was the precursor to what subsequently became the reporting layer in Power BI.
These three segments Power Query, Power Pivot,
and Power View were then packaged together into
Power BI to create a single application that can extract,
transform, and load the data,
then model the data,
and finally produce interactive reports.
Power BI is constantly being improved and these improvements are crowdsourced.
This is one of the things I really love about the software.
There's a whole community that's grown up around it.
Here we can see a screenshot of
the Power BI Ideas website where Microsoft actively collects data from the community.
In addition to lots of meetups and knowledge sharing among the users,
the Power BI team is also always encouraging
feedback and suggestions to continue meeting end-users needs.
They report out on these each month with
a monthly Power BI update on their YouTube channel so the tools are always improving.
As we just saw, the technologies underlying Power BI were
originally developed and used in other parts of the Microsoft ecosystem.
That means many of the things you'll learn in this course
for Power BI can be applied elsewhere.
For example, here we see that Power BI shares a lot of
DNA with Excel and Azure tabular data modeling.
Starting with Power Query and M Code,
these technologies are available in Excel's get data in
the tabular data modeling portion of Azure Analysis Services and in Power BI Desktop,
although their name's slightly different in Excel.
Similarly, the M Code that supports all of these in Power Query is equally available.
With tabular data modeling, the vertipaq engine,
DAX formulas you use to calculate on top of the vertipaq engine,
and the relationships that create the sinew between different models in the data model
itself are also available in all three of these technologies.
Really the only area where functionally they're going to be very different is that you
can develop a report that you can load to
PowerBI.com off of Azure Analysis Services and Power BI Desktop.
You can still use a Power Pivot Data Model in PowerBI.com,
but it's a little bit more complicated.